seven animals that will restore your
faith in long-term relationships here
are some of the most dedicated couples
of the animal kingdom the alpha male and
female wolf are often the
decision-makers in the back and it is
common for this power couple to be
monogamous so once it's level on for
male and female Small's to become mates
for life raising their children together
year after year of all the Eagles also
they spend much of their time alone
about Eagle will come back to the same
mate for years
barn owls what about and will sometimes
separate when bleating isn't working out
they are typically monogamous the bones
the bones are one of the very few
primates to practice monogamy a pair of
key bones can stay united and even high
as a family together
giant cleaver or tails giant river
otters in groups can be aggressive
enough to take down an alligator yet
even they are capable of long-term
monogamous relationships your Hopi
Imperius even some North American
beavers are known to sleep around your
Hopi and beavers are known to be
monogamous in fact a genetic offspring
study of one colony found 100% of
playfulness way to go European beavers
thanks mother nature forgiving us ashtag
relationship goals
[Music]